[Music]
[Applause]
tsunami
t is silent honest h is silent
island s is silent q
u is silence bullies school is science
wait a minute what'd i just say i am 14
and this is like my new microphone
it's jack's microphone i forgot mine so
he'll lend it to me
it's very enticing i kind of want to do
dirty things with it
but i must hold myself for it is not
mine to violate sexually
and orally just know that i want to very
deeply
other things are a deep 14 year olds no
wait that's so
sorry today we're reviewing i'm 14 and
this is d
this is a classic subreddit
it's beautiful i love it i love it so
much
14 year old fell in deep hole next to
his house
you know that person was 14 and have
been dipping
deep as hell dude you gotta respect
thing don't call yourself 14 and not
being deep like this boy
is he okay should i be laughing at this
i'm in green lakes upstate new york it's
about 200 feet deep
i'm 14 by the way well you're not in the
lake are you dumbass
don't waste my time 14 year olds this
facebook logo makes sense now
because the giant f on an app called
facebook
didn't make sense before thank god we
have discovered this
i was so confused but now
i am enlightened i am enlightened
i understand everything in the universe
the f
in the f where your book logo is a man
staring down on the phone
ask me anything for i am deepest of them
all
[Music]
i'm tired of hearing how everything in
your life wasn't good enough
including me i'm laughing so hard
someone made this gif
black and white to make it more dramatic
but it's literally from a movie about a
talking fish
and a vegetarian shark no
it's deep you don't understand
the black one is called a killer that
white one is called grey
[Music]
no
do you feel it do you feel the
enlightenment just striking you like
actual lightning
i understand the world butch gave her
all she wanted
tom gave her all he had
[Music]
my god me when i actually find something
deep on this subreddit
maybe maybe i am
[Music]
ah what's that anime icon avatar that
everyone had that's black and white
and there's a guy crying ah you wouldn't
understand my range of emotion
[Music]
a bunch of betters i never cried in my
life
yeah the bart simpson one works too just
put some low-fi hip-hop over it and my
god i'm
i've experienced such unique emotions
that no one ever had
i'll have a billy alicia's bad meme how
original
and her music is for 14 year old girls
daring today are we
wow you made an observation that no one
else ever has
incredible cigarettes are food for
broken souls
oh your soul is broken
i make people happy go away weed bad
influence
i wake people up so they can work like
robots coffee
my lifesaver oh my god guys this is so
true have you ever thought about this
cocaine i make people happy and more
energetic but coffee bad
what the society make all drugs legal
now society
or else i'll deep throat this microphone
don't ask me why i'm silent
because if i speak then i will speak
only
about black holes time travel
quantum physics etc and then everyone
else
will remain silent
someone made this i think i will not
speak to you
thank you very much
entry men women damn
that's powerful one of my favorite posts
here
this pressure for meant to be scratch
shaped
really pisses me off sometimes i'm glad
that you all
understand women never understand
in this industry a girl freaks up what
the fake
such a worthless piece of [ __ ] also go
die in the hole
guy [ __ ] up oh my god king don't worry
everyone makes mistake we know you have
a good heart and we'll be here for you
forever
excuse me i don't believe you have to be
a scrub [ __ ] square [ __ ]
disgusting the hypocrisy i want a nokia
but society won't let me just buy a
[ __ ] nokia
no one gives a [ __ ]
why do i even bother no one's gonna buy
my sasuke painting
why does no one buy myself skip anything
no one understands no one can possibly
understand the pain of banana
art world read the first letter of each
emoji
i am an
uh
[Music]
dude goosebumps
holy heck dude
ice apple mountain eyes nose pig apple
eyes nose
[Music]
the [ __ ] did you just say ice apple
mountain
why does no one understand my eyes apple
why does no one understand my pig apple
eyes nose
you don't understand my pig apple eyes
nose mom
no one understands me pig apple light's
nose
don't be ugly don't be young don't be
racist
just be you damn let it really be the
best place
the epic wholesome pewdiepie chu
chunga chunga chunga reeves moment right
there i really felt
my soul when i die i want my heart
donated to nasa
so they can finally see what the black
hole looks like nice
holy [ __ ] dude they got a [ __ ] black
hole in here
what the [ __ ] yeah what happened to all
emos like what do they do now
huh what are you up to little emos what
are you just conspired they're hiding in
the shadows you know they're up to
something
they're up to no good god damn it the
power of
water the most beautiful photo you'll
see to get
today man's gonna drown dude
see this shows everything wrong with
society why is there not water society
huh you don't care about handicaps is
that why
vote for leader for what their society
now
sugar and salt looks almost same
hold up hold no hold up here
hold that no sugar and salt look
almost the same oh my god
oh my god dude that's [ __ ] crazy
oh my god i'm enlightened i understand
everything
sugar and salt looks almost the same and
same as an
s2 sss there must be some cryptic
message here what if we convert
it into emojis all right name these
brands okay la co
la cost apple mcdonald's facebook
volkswagen nike
name these plants uh we got some
maple we got some oh god i don't know
all of them
oh my god they slap you in the
oh my god i felt that reality just
slapped me in the face right there
love her music but this belongs here can
everyone stop
being everyone else no flipping way
this is funny because everyone that
likes billy ellis seems to dress like
her
did you stop stealing my style god damn
it
i literally cannot survive without
injecting pubg to my
blood stream why is pump g in there
i gotta have it bro i gotta get that
chicken dinner or else i starve
you don't understand mom black or white
we are all the same inside racism cured
everybody
we did it thanks to two eggs that's all
it took
we will look back on this day in the
history books to the men that compare
the eggs
i can't believe this man just fix raises
him he did it
bravo what am i even looking at
[Music]
toilet brain tick-tock bad i mean i hate
tick tock but man what the hell is this
we live in a society where pizza gets to
your house
before the police thank you garut
thank you i never thought about that one
before next time my house is getting
robbed i'll call the pizza
man i'll call 20 pizzerias they should
all be able to take them out right
plus they have pizzas too you can throw
them in the face like frisbees
plus then we'll know which one is
stronger papa john's or dominos i've
always wondered
someone saved me from this never-ending
nightmare
this mcdonald's makes shake i don't know
why
i started drinking it it's a nightmare i
can't help me
help me will someone save bethany please
she's 14 it's tough to slurp her slurp
girl
delete her boy okay boy delete him girl
but he's my friend
[Music]
today's lesson go crazy boy simp pretty
accurate i would say
well done so tell me where should i go
to the left
where nothing is right or to the right
whereas
nothing is left
sorry i'm sorry
men are like bluetooth oh boy i look
forward to hear this one
he's connected to you when you are
nearby but searches for other devices
when you're away
women are like wi-fi they poopy be open
for anyone
no she sees all available devices but
connects to the strongest one
nice bluetooth can only connect to one
device at a time and would need
confirmation from both devices to
connect successfully
wi-fi connects to multiple devices and
can be set without a password
women's are women are hoarse basically
thank you wifi i knew it
i'm joking by the way where gold medals
are won
where gold medals are earned just keep
swimming out in the ocean
that's where you earn your gold medal
what the hell is this
me on the outside me and the inside i
mean probably
damn thomas the tank engine sock
spitting facts dude
parents your room is a mess you should
see my life
nobody likes you nobody loves you nobody
thinks you're pretty nobody wants to
talk to you nobody wants
you to live don't worry my name is
nobody
your name is paul pavlovsky shut the
[ __ ] up
i'll tell you about quantum physics and
theory of relativity
i will tell you about your future
why does no one want to know about
quantum physics
i'm the only one that likes quantum
physics
it's such a struggle i have no one to
talk to you about quantum fix i get
their
relativity oh my god it's me okay a
woman slightly is tested when her man
has nothing a man's loyalty is tested
when he has
everything what god damn it
god damn it guys are you 14 i thought we
were through this
you're 9 or 19 not 14.
god damn it i've never been so
disappointed
you it works both ways plus
i've never said this my sister never
said this no one has ever said this
ah oh you're ruined i'm supposed to make
fun of these
not you oh my god i've never been so
disappointed
phone is dead laptop's dead i'm
dead i'm dead my dude god damn it
the more you know the dumber you sound
to stupid people
mom none of the pictures in the club
want to know about quantum physics
are you a winning son no one wants to
read about the quantum physics i don't
understand
where do you work out at the library me
this head with that body that's me
that's fitly right there
the most ascended enlightened individual
on the planet
never take advice from someone that
isn't in peak foresee
never oh water is so nice water doesn't
call me an idiot
water
huge props huge props whoever took time
to do that well done
i'm fine my twin however is having a
mental breakdown
he's been punching the ground on stop
for hours someone make him stop please
i feel great however thanks for asking
some people smoke to enjoy it
i smoke to die yeah i'm sure you'll
enjoy it so much when you're going
through chemotherapy dumb
shut up sad but true truly sad
if inner beauty is what really mattered
the gym wouldn't be so crowded
the library would never be so empty we
need gyms
and the library i keep telling you guys
fitlife
fitlit junk food balanced meal
rest in peace logic wait logic died oh
no
i thought he was gonna stream on twitch
thank you for watching this episode i'm
14 and deep i sure feel
deeper than ever
i am invited smash live for more
enlightened content and i'll see you
guys tomorrow
unless i end it here right now i
shouldn't joke about that okay hero
ah children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean
[Music]